ironically I think the most important
part of the venture capitalist job is
actually picking and deciding where you
want to invest you maybe make those
decisions a couple times a year they
drive so much of the value and the
return and that's the most important
part of the job I'm Thalia Goldberg I'm
a vice president at customer Venture
Partners and I'm 26 years old
it's a venture capital firm which means
that we give money and resources and
support to innovative companies that are
growing quickly sometimes we invest in
these companies at the early stages when
they're just getting started sometimes
really two people in an idea and
sometimes much later on when there's a
real company and significant momentum
and they're just looking for a capital
to grow I'm a little bit of a VC by
accident initially when I was getting
started in school I pursued both the
business degree at Penn as well as a
liberal arts degree and I was so excited
by what was happening in the startup
scene and different technology companies
that were really pushing the boundaries
moving the fastest and so I joined a
number of startup throughout college
like Foursquare and Pink's simple and
worked on a company of my own for a
while I really loved the culture and the
spirit of innovation in entrepreneurship
but it wasn't what I was meant to do and
I had a friend at the time who was
working at Bessemer and encouraged me to
interview as they were recruiting I
ended up meeting the team and thinking
that there were some of the kind of
smartest most humble people that had
really interesting jobs I thought I
would join for two years and then end up
joining a start-up or starting my own
company and figuring out what I really
wanted to do but it turns out that I
really loved investing
[Music]
in some ways I think that I'm still
waiting for my big break like I still
have a lot to prove what's gotten me to
this point is that the best term for it
is grit or persistence and I think
that's something that I've certainly
think about myself I'm trying to break
through barriers and walk through walls
and it's every single day pushing the
boundaries working incredibly hard and
there's no real one big break at least
that I've had yet maybe I'll be
fortunate enough someday to get that and
you sort of have to create your own luck
because luck is really hard to bet on
[Music]